[Music]
let's go to octavia in los angeles
what's up octavia
how are you i am rocking until the break
of dawn how are you
i cannot complain yes you can you'd be
like the rest of everybody but i'm happy
that you're not so good so what's up
well i just wanted to get a little bit
of advice um life just kind of went
crazy and um
you know i just want to see where
you'll be able to help me at and see if
maybe you can give me some cool advice
on moving forward out of this crazy
situation
all right let's do it i'm down some cool
advice
all right
so um back i would say in may um i had a
landlord who
um wanted to wrongfully evict me stating
that someone else lived in my unit who
did it
and um so we went through this whole um
eviction process where i had to combat
the eviction
and in the midst of there my stuff was
locked into the unit um so on june 23rd
some kids got into the unit
playing and burnt my house down
and
yeah okay hold on
hold on so you're
were you behind on rent
no so he stated that someone lived into
the unit that didn't live in the unit um
did you have somebody over there a lot
like a friend or something then he
wanted to charge that person rent
no that's the thing um i had to go
through this whole thing to prove to him
that no one lived there and i did and
he stated that he was going to go and
clear the eviction with the courts or
however
and he never did
so all of a sudden i get this letter
that states that i have to leave out by
within the next three days
and for my knowledge everything was
cleared between the gentleman and i and
um long story short he lied
and so we went to court he lied in court
and um
yeah that's how come it went up to where
i had to actually
dispute it
did you win did you win the dispute
so in the midst of trying to do the
dispute is when the house burned down so
there's nothing to dispute anymore you
know who burned it
there still is actually but who burned
it down your your nephews
no it was actually some people that
lived in the complex um and it was it's
cool it's documented and everything the
fire marshals came the boy went to jail
and everything was set in stone in that
aspect um of knowing who did it
but the thing is um
it's been very hard for me to find a
lawyer since then
that would take this case for i was
advised that it's for negligence because
um on paper the
young gentleman who burnt the house down
did state that all they did was slide
the window open so that means when the
landlord and the constable went to quote
unquote evict me
um they were supposed to lock up the
unit and they didn't because the little
kids said we slid the window open that's
how we got into the unit so the boy got
in trouble
but i still need help with um
you know the situation with the landlord
for negligence
and on top of that um negligence in my
experience is a very high legal standard
to meet
it's hard
um
you've got to
i say that like
it's got to be very clear let me put it
that way like there's a hole in the
sidewalk and you step in and break your
leg like it's got to be very very clear
yeah
and that like what you're describing to
me just on his face i'm no attorney and
so i can't give you legal advice that
sounds like
a standard that would be nearly
impossible to meet did you have renters
insurance
so at the time i didn't um i i just
learned that um
i had
cancelled my renters insurance when the
eviction process started
um i was advised that i have a really
amazing case because everything's
already documented the court marshals
they've already given me an estimate of
how much my stuff was in the house
the boy already was deemed guilty the
his lawyer stated that if i go after him
he does have to pay
so i have the chief of the fire
department stuff i have all the
paperwork from the um police department
so how can i help you
so
um
going through all of that obviously made
me and my children homeless
and i have a 10 year old and a
six-year-old and after june 23rd when
the house burned down october
20th my daughter's dad passed away
so
that put me in a really hard financial
bind um i don't know any like no one in
my family has ever financially made it
anywhere um okay so hold on if you have
a place that you're staying
and it burns down like if you're in a
hotel or if you're in an apartment
part of your lease states that they have
to find an alternative place for you to
live
they did not do that i know but i'm
saying is that you need to go to them
and say hey per my lease
um
you've got to find it you've got to
provide me another place and i've had
people whose um apartments catch on fire
and they just live in a hotel for a
while and the apartment complex has to
pay that
um
or if something
they've got to provide you a place
to be
i was not aware of that um me and my
kids move pretty much to a homeless
shelter okay i would circle back um and
here's the other thing
do you have the money to pay rent
i mean i'm working now i am working now
um i bet it's part time so
i
have saved up money and i was just
trying to go through this program to try
to um
the road try to get me into like a place
or something
and i have been going through this
program pretty much since my place burnt
down
and i know that um you know i've just
been trying to look into
different things you know i'm definitely
into owning my own business
obviously i can't really do that in a
situation not having my own place
what you need right now more than
anything else
is
like you've been through a lot
yeah
and my guess is how old are your little
ones
um ten and six okay mine are 12 and six
okay
and um is dad around at all or no
um he passed okay oh that's where you
told me
yeah
so like literally by myself yeah yeah
yeah
i left that state because it all
happened in las vegas that's kind of
what brought me here
um but you can go through this program
hold on
let's take a second
like the worst of the worst of the worst
has happened to you
and you're running and running and
running okay
so i need you to hear me say this really
clearly
when traumatic things happen our bod our
brains roll back into a very primitive
state which is one of survival one of
fighting or fleeing or hiding
okay
and when our brain is stressed like that
we make very immediate decisions to try
to get to the next second
and that's often what traps people in
cycles that are very hard to get out of
okay
and so what i want you to do for just a
second
can you take a really deep breath for me
as deep as you can and just hold it
hold it
hold on blow it out that wasn't even
deep enough
do you vape
no good you can you can breathe deeper
than that then give it a shot breathe
deep
hold it
let it out
then i want you to drop your shoulders i
want you to pull them down okay
what was what was um your child's
father's name
charles was it your husband
just long-term long-term partner
yes okay so
charles is gone
and your home is gone
and i know you're running around trying
to super glue and duct tape and take
some string and sufficient line and try
to hold your kid's life together in your
life together
but the path forward to sitting down for
a second and just putting your face in
your hands
okay you've got to give your body a
chance to settle into this
is what i'm saying ring and true
yes
i'm so sorry this happened to you
what just happened right in a road you
should not happen to anybody
not to mention the stress they were
already trying to take your house away
until some knucklehead burned it down
and at least you had to ride or die
until he passed and now you're in a mess
okay yeah
sprinting and running and thinking about
starting a new business that is down the
road right now
um you may have heard me say this on
this show buy your hand not by your hand
but in your lap
you didn't cause this stuff but here it
is and so the dreams and the excitement
and the things
that just got pushed off because the
world just hit you in the mouth
okay
and i hate hate in my guts that it did
so why did why of the one of the most
expensive places to live in the united
states is los angeles california why'd
you pick there
um
it's so funny that it really is but at
the same time
um
this is the one state that helps you you
know las vegas didn't have that i was
pretty much sleeping in my car
and i'm coming here although i'm in this
program that's you know it's like a
homeless shelter like pretty much women
with children in these huge houses
and um
they're helping me with las vegas i had
nothing um
you know the red cross didn't want to
help me um
no like i had nothing at least out here
it is the most expensive but i know that
everyone's afraid of scared world but
you don't have to be there like there
really are programs that give you
housing they wanna help you you look for
a place they'll help you um
you know um different stuff like that
and then coming out here i ended up
getting a really good job and but but
it's part time right
yeah
all right so here's your moving forward
goal
like my heart's broken for you
you're moving forward goal here is
putting on a calendar like maybe 24
months
maybe 18 months
and you are gonna take this hurt
and this anger which should be real
someone burnt your house down charles
died man you should be pissed off
and heartbroken and sad all those things
and those two beautiful little kids
you know what i mean
who are hurting also
24 months
of maniacal
intense
i'm gonna work two jobs and four jobs
and seven jobs
or i may have to i know there's a cool
program and i know it's los angeles and
i know there's like some walk right in
for some setup
but if you got a family member in kansas
who will just let you hang on for 24
months
or if you got a family member in rhode
island or oregon
and you can
drum up some nickels and quarters and i
know gas is basically
liquid gold these days
but here's the thing
i just um
this morning was in a meeting with my
team
and a woman owed 267 thousand dollars
all on her own
and she said never again
and she worked that way never again
and most people don't work that way
never again for two reasons number one
there's not a path forward
like i don't know what that looks like
even
and two the world has told you that
you're powerless you're not worth being
in relationship with
and i i need you to hear me say octavia
you are strong
do you believe that
yes i do
you didn't say that with much confidence
you were much more confident about how
great the service the the services are
in california do you believe you are
strong
yes i i do okay
nobody in your family lineage has
handled money well have they
no no
you will be the one who changes your
family tree are you in
yes of course okay there's a great quote
by terry reel who's a therapist who i
love
and he said
family dysfunction and family trauma
rolls downhill
burns through families like a forest
fire until one person
turns to stare it down and says no more
and that person gets scars and burned
and does not have all the shiny stuff
but their kids do
right
right so i'm going to set you up here's
what i'm going to give you
um you know i work here at ramsey
solutions so i'm going to give you a
year subscription for free to ramsey
plus what that is is
that is how to do money 101.
starting from the ground up it's the
same plan i use me and my family
that most of everyone who works here
does
it's the same plan that took dave from
getting
losing everything
to becoming he's got hundreds of million
dollars i can't count his net worth okay
but it all starts
at square one okay i'm gonna give you
that i'm also gonna send you a book
called total money makeover that's gonna
teach you about how to take control of
your money okay
i'm also gonna send you
my buddy ken's book
called paycheck to purpose did you
already send that to you
no okay i'm gonna send you that here's
what that job is i mean that book is
it's about how to get start from square
one
from zero
to go get work
that matters to you and that you matter
to the work because they're both of
those are important okay and
i'm gonna send you a copy of my book and
here's what my book's about just came
out it's number one bestseller
my book is
so you've had a life of trauma
and the world kept hitting you and it
kept hitting you and when you thought
you couldn't take no more then they took
charles
and
my book walks you through
and then the back half of that book is
so what do i do now
how do i stand back up on my two feet
how do i get a community around me how
do i look at my two little kids and say
we're in this together ride or die and
i'm gonna be the mama that none of the
people in my lineage have been before
okay i'm gonna send you all that
here's my prom you have to promise me
okay yes
a
with the ramsey with the um
ramsay plus
you have to watch all of the videos you
promise there's like nine of them that's
it promise i promise were you watching
with your ten-year-old
yes watching with your six year old two
we're changing family tree stuff here
right
yes
will you commit to finding a place to
live if you have to be in services for
the next i'll give you six months in los
angeles okay
the way you just described the services
there is how people get trapped
because it is good there are some great
like your house just burned down here's
a place to come stay
but that can't be a two-year five-year
10-year plan for you okay
in los angeles i could not afford to
live in los angeles and i make a lot of
money i don't make a lot of money i do
well okay
i can't move there
you hear what i'm saying so at some
point you're going to say all right
what's my path out of here
and paycheck to purpose will help you
figure that out okay
do you have somebody you can share life
with right now you have a friend a
relative somebody that can walk
alongside you
um
not really but okay i want you to
whether you go down to a local church
whether you
find somebody and scrounge up some
nickels and buy coffee
um whether you get with one of the other
moms in that home that you're in
you have to make a connection with
another human you cannot do this by
yourself okay
okay you promise you'll do that
i promise you know why because you're
worth being in a relationship with and
you're worth being loved and you're
worth having somebody by your side fair
yes that's fair okay so today this all
changes yes that's that's what i need
set today this all changes
today this all changes this is what i'm
talking about
and it might not all change you may go
back to the same shelter and you may go
have the same place with your kids and
your kids are getting out of school and
you're trying to figure out day camp for
summer and stuff like that
but in your head and then you're in your
guts
today is the day this thing all changes
right
right
so proud of you octavia today's the day
man
read the books
watch the lessons
find somebody to do life with it's gonna
be hard sledding for a few years hard
sledding and you're worth every single
step of the way